[Music]
an old man named daniel baker
living near lebanon iowa was suspected
by his neighbors of having murdered a
peddler who had obtained permission to
pass the night at his house
this was in 1853 when peddling was more
common in the western country than it is
now
and was attended with considerable
danger
the peddler with his pack traversed the
country by all manner of lonely roads
and was compelled to rely upon the
country people for hospitality
this brought him into relation with
queer characters
some of whom were not altogether
scrupulous in their methods of making a
living
murder being an acceptable means to that
end
it occasionally occurred that a peddler
with diminished pack and swollen purse
would be traced to the lonely dwelling
of some rough character
and never could be traced beyond this
was so in the case of old man baker
as he was always called such names are
given in the western settlements only to
elderly persons who are not esteemed
to the general disrepute of social
unworth is affixed the special reproach
of age
a peddler came to his house and none
went away
that is all that anybody knew seven
years later
the reverend mr cummings a baptist
minister well known in that part of the
country
was driving by baker's farm one night it
was not very dark
there was a bit of moon somewhere above
the light veil of mist that lay along
the earth
mr cummings who was at all times a
cheerful person
was whistling a tune which he would
occasionally interrupt
to speak a word of friendly
encouragement to his horse
as he came to a little bridge across a
dry ravine
he saw the figure of a man standing upon
it clearly outlined against the gray
background of a misty forest
the man had something strapped on his
back and carried a heavy stick
obviously an itinerant peddler his
attitude had ended a suggestion of
abstraction like that of a sleepwalker
mr cummings reigned in his horse when he
arrived in front of him
gave him a pleasant salutation and
invited him to a seat in the vehicle
if you were going my way he added the
man raised his head
looked him full in the face but neither
answered nor made any further movement
the minister with good-natured
persistence repeated his invitation
at this the man threw his right hand
forward from his side
and pointed downward as he stood on the
extreme edge of the bridge
mr cummings looked past him over into
the ravine
saw nothing unusual and withdrew his
eyes to address the man again
he had disappeared the horse which all
this time had been
uncommonly restless gave at the same
moment a snort of terror and started to
run away
before he had regained control of the
animal the minister was at the crest of
the hill a hundred yards along
he looked back and saw the figure again
at the same place
and in the same attitude as when he had
first observed it
then for the first time he was conscious
of a sense of the supernatural
and drove home as rapidly as his willing
horse would go
on arriving at home he related his
adventure to his family
and early the next morning accompanied
by two neighbors
john white corwell and abner razor
returned to the spot
they found the body of old man baker
hanging by the neck
from one of the beams of the bridge
immediately beneath the spot where the
apparition had stood
a thick coating of dust slightly
dampened by the mist
covered the floor of the bridge but the
only footprints were those of mr
cummings's
horse in taking down the body
the men disturbed the loose friable
earth of the slope below it
disclosing human bones already nearly
uncovered by the action of water and
frost
they were identified as those of the
lost peddler
at the double inquest the coroner's jury
found that daniel baker died by his own
hand
while suffering from temporary insanity
and that samuel moritz was murdered by
some person or persons to the jury
unknown
in the summer of 1896 mr william holt
a wealthy manufacturer of chicago was
living temporarily in a little town in
central new york
the name of which the writer's memory
has not retained
mr holt had had trouble with his wife
from whom he had parted a year before
whether the trouble was anything more
serious than incompatibility of temper
he is probably the only living person
who knows he is not addicted to the vice
of confidences
yet he has related the incident herein
set down to at least one person without
exacting a pledge of secrecy
he is now living in europe one evening
he had left the house of a brother whom
he was visiting
for a stroll in the country it may be
assumed
whatever the value of the assumption and
connection with what is said to have
occurred
that his mind was occupied with
reflections on his domestic
infillicities
and the distressing changes that they
had wrought in his life
whatever may have been his thoughts they
so possessed him that he observed
neither the lapse of time
nor whether his feet were carrying him
he knew only that he had passed far
beyond the town limits and was
traversing a lonely region
by a road that bore no resemblance to
the one by which he had left the village
in brief he was lost realizing his
mischance he smiled
central new york is not a region of
perils nor does one long remain lost in
it
he turned about and went back the way
that he had come
before he had gone far he observed that
the landscape was growing more distinct
was brightening everything was suffused
with a soft red glow
in which he saw his shadow projected in
the road before him
the moon is rising he said to himself
then he remembered that it was about the
time of the new moon
and if that trixie orb was in one of its
stages of visibility it had set long
before
he stopped and faced about seeking the
source of the rapidly broadening light
as he did so his shadow turned and lay
along the road in front of him as before
the light still came from behind him
that was surprising
he could not understand again he turned
and again facing successively to every
point of the horizon
always the shadow as before always the
light behind
a still and awful red holt was
astonished
dumbfounded is the word that he used in
telling it yet seems to have retained a
certain intelligent curiosity
to test the intensity of the light whose
nature and cause he could not determine
he took out his watch to see if he could
make out the figures on the dial
they were plainly visible and the hands
indicated the hour of 11 o'clock and 25
minutes
at that moment the mysterious
illumination suddenly flared to an
intense and almost blinding splendor
flushing the entire sky extinguishing
the stars and throwing the monstrous
shadow of himself a thwart the landscape
in that unearthly illumination he saw
near him but apparently in the air
at a considerable elevation the figure
of his wife
clad in her night clothing and holding
to her breasts the figure of his child
her eyes were fixed upon his with an
expression which he afterward professed
himself
unable to name or describe further than
that
it was not of this life the flare was
momentary
followed by black darkness in which
however the apparition
still showed white and motionless then
by insensible degrees it faded and
vanished
like a bright image on the retina after
the closing of the eyes
a peculiarity of the apparition hardly
noted at the time but afterward recalled
was that it showed only the upper half
of the woman's figure
nothing was seen below the waist the
sudden darkness was comparative
not absolute for gradually all objects
of his environment became again
visible in the dawn of the morning holt
found himself entering the village at a
point opposite to that at which he had
left it
he soon arrived at the house of his
brother who hardly knew him
he was wild-eyed haggard and gray as a
rat
almost incoherently he related his
night's experience
go to bed my poor fellow said his
brother and wait
we shall hear more of this an hour later
came the predestined telegram holt's
dwelling
in one of the suburbs of chicago had
been destroyed by fire
her escape cut off by the flames his
wife had appeared at an upper window
her child in her arms there she had
stood
motionless apparently dazed
just as the firemen had arrived with a
ladder the floor had given way
and she was seen no more the moment of
this culminating horror
was 11 o'clock and 25 minutes standard
[Music]
time
[Music]
philip eckert lived for many years in an
old weather-stained wooden house
about three miles from the little town
of marion in vermont
there must be quite a number of persons
living who remember him not unkindly i
trust
and know something of the story that i
am about to tell
old man eckert as he was always called
was not of a sociable disposition and
lived alone
as he was never known to speak of his
own affairs nobody thereabout knew
anything of his past
nor of his relatives if he had any
without being particularly ungracious or
repellent in manner or speech
he managed somehow to be immune to
impertinent curiosity yet exempt from
the evil repute with which it commonly
revenges itself when baffled
so far as i know mr eckhart's renown as
a reformed assassin or a retired pirate
of the spanish maine
had not reached any ear in marion he got
his living cultivating a small and not
very fertile farm
one day he disappeared and a prolonged
search by his neighbors failed to turn
him up
or throw any light upon his whereabouts
or why abouts
nothing indicated preparation to leave
all was as he might have left it to go
to the spring for a bucket of water
for a few weeks little else was talked
of in that region
then old man eckert became a village
tale for the ear of the stranger
i do not know what was done regarding
his property the correct legal thing
doubtless the house was standing still
vacant and conspicuously unfit
when i last heard of it some 20 years
afterward
of course it came to be considered
haunted and the customary tales were
told of moving lights
dolorous sounds and startling
apparitions
at one time about five years after the
disappearance
these stories of the supernatural became
so rife
or through some attesting circumstances
seemed so important
that some of marion's most serious
citizens deemed it well to investigate
and to that end arranged for a night
session on the premises
the parties to this undertaking were
john holcomb an apothecary
wilson merle a lawyer and andrus c
palmer the teacher of the public school
all men of consequence and repute they
were to meet at holcomb's house at eight
o'clock in the evening of the appointed
day and go together to the scene of
their vigil where certain arrangements
for their comfort
a provision of fuel and the like for the
season was winter
had already been made palmer did not
keep the engagement
and after waiting a half hour for him
the others went to the eckerd house
without him
they established themselves in the
principal room before a glowing fire
and without other light than it gave
awaited events
it had been agreed to speak as little as
possible they did not even renew the
exchange of views regarding the
defection of palmer
which had occupied their minds on the
way
probably an hour had passed without
incident when they heard
not without emotion doubtless the sound
of an opening
door in the rear of the house followed
by footfalls
in the room adjoining that in which they
sat the watchers rose to their feet
but stood firm prepared for whatever
might ensue
a long silence followed how long neither
would afterward undertake to say
then the door between the two rooms
opened and a man
entered it was palmer he was pale
as if from excitement as pale as the
others felt themselves to
be his manner too was singularly
distracted
he neither responded to their
salutations nor so much as looked at
them
but walked slowly across the room in the
light of the failing fire
and opening the front door passed out
into the darkness
it seems to have been the first thought
of both men that palmer was suffering
from fright
that something seen heard or imagined in
the back room
had deprived him of his senses acting on
the same
friendly impulse both ran after him
through the open door
but neither they nor anyone ever again
saw or heard of andrus palmer
this much was ascertained the next
morning during the session of mr
holcomb and mr merle at the haunted
house a new snow had fallen
to a depth of several inches upon the
old
in this snow palmer's trail from his
lodging in the village to the back door
of the eckert house
was conspicuous but there it ended
from the front door nothing led away but
the tracks of the two men who swore that
he preceded them
palmer's disappearance was as complete
as that of old man eckerd himself
whom indeed the editor of the local
paper somewhat graphically accused of
having
reached out and pulled him in
[Music]
it was as far as i can ascertain in
september of the year 1811
that a post chase drew up before the
door of azerby hall
in the heart of lincolnshire the little
boy who was the only passenger in the
chase
and who jumped out as soon as it had
stopped looked about him with the
keenest curiosity
during the short interval that elapsed
between the ringing of the bell
and the opening of the hall door he saw
a tall
square red brick house built in the
reign of anne
a stone-pillared porch had been added in
the purer classical style
of 1790 the windows of the house were
many
tall and narrow with small panes and
thick white woodwork
a pediment pierced with a round window
crowned the front
there were wings to right and left
connected by curious glazed galleries
supported by colonnades with a central
block
these wings plainly contained the
stables and offices of the house
each was surmounted by an ornamental
cupola with a gilded vein
an evening light shown on the building
making the window panes glow like so
many fires
away from the hall in front stretched a
flat park studded with oaks infringed
with furs
which stood out against the sky the
clock in the church tower
buried in trees on the edge of the park
only its golden weather [ __ ]
catching the light was striking six and
the sound came
gently beating down the wind it was
altogether a pleasant impression
though tinged with the sort of
melancholy appropriate to an evening in
early autumn
that was conveyed to the mind of the boy
who was standing in the porch waiting
for the door to open to him
he had just come from warwickshire and
some six months ago had been left an
orphan
now owing to the generous and unexpected
offer of his elderly cousin mr abney
he had come to live at azerbaiy the
offer was unexpected
because all who knew anything of mr
abney looked upon him as a somewhat
austere recluse
into whose steady-going household the
advent of a small boy
would import a new and it seemed
incongruous element
the truth is that very little was known
of mr abney's pursuits or temper
the professor of greek at cambridge had
been heard to say that no one knew more
of the religious beliefs of the later
pagans
than did the owner of azerby certainly
his library contained all the then
available books
bearing on the mysteries the orphic
poems the worship of mithras
and the neoplatonists in the marble
paved hall stood a fine group of mithras
slaying a bull
which had been imported from the levant
at great expense by the owner
he had contributed a description of it
to the gentleman's magazine
and he had written a remarkable series
of articles in the critical museum
on the superstitions of the romans of
the lower empire
he was looked upon and fine as a man
wrapped up in his books
and it was a matter of great surprise
among his neighbors that he should ever
have heard of his orphan cousin
stephen elliott much more that he should
have volunteered to make him an inmate
of azerby hall
whatever may have been expected by his
neighbors it is certain that mr abney
the tall the thin the austere seemed
inclined to give his young cousin a
kindly reception
the moment the front door was opened he
darted out of his study
rubbing his hands with delight how are
you my boy how are you
how old are you said he that is you are
not too much tired i hope
by your journey to eat your supper no
thank you sir
said master elliot i am pretty well
that's a good lad
said mr abney and how old are you my boy
it seemed a little odd that he should
have asked the question twice
in the first two minutes of their
acquaintance i'm 12 years old next
birthday sir
said stephen and when is your birthday
my dear boy
11th of september eh that's well that's
very well
nearly a year hence isn't it i like to
get these things down in my book
sure it's 12 certain yes
quite sure sir well well take him to mrs
bunch's room parks
and let him have his tea supper whatever
it is
yes sir answered the staid mr parks and
conducted stephen to the lower regions
mrs bunch was the most comfortable and
human person whom stephen had as yet
met in aserby she made him completely at
home
they were great friends in a quarter of
an hour and great friends they remained
mrs bunch had been born in the
neighborhood some 55 years before the
date of steven's arrival
and her residence at the hall was of 20
years standing
consequently if anyone knew the ins and
outs of the house and the district
mrs bunch knew them and she was by no
means disinclined to communicate her
information
certainly there were plenty of things
about the hall and the hall gardens
which stephen who was of an adventurous
and inquiring turn
was anxious to have explained to him who
built the temple at the end of the
laurel walk
who was the old man whose picture hung
on the staircase
sitting at a table with a skull under
his hand these and many similar points
were cleared up by the resources of mrs
bunch's powerful intellect
there were others however of which the
explanations furnished were less
satisfactory
one november evening stephen was sitting
by the fire in the housekeeper's room
reflecting on his surroundings is mr
abney a good man
and will he go to heaven he suddenly
asked with the peculiar confidence which
children possess
and the ability of their elders to
settle these questions
the decision of which is believed to be
reserved for other tribunals
good bless the child said mrs bunch
masters as kind to soul as ever i see
didn't i ever
tell you the little boy that he took in
out of the street as you may say
this seven years back and the little
girl two years after i first came here
no do tell me all about them mrs bunch
now this minute
well said mrs bunch the little girl i
don't seem to recollect so much about
i know master brought her back with him
from his walk one day
and gave orders to mrs ellis who was
housekeeper then
as she should be taken every care with
and the poor child had no one belonging
to her
she told me so her own self and here she
lived with us
a matter of three weeks it might be and
then whether she was something of a
gypsy in her blood or whatnot
but one morning she was out of her bed
before any of us had opened an eye
and neither track nor yet trace of her
have i set eyes on since
master was wonderful put about and had
all the pawns dragged
but it's my belief she was had away by
them gypsies
for there was singing round the house
for as much as an hour the night she
went
and parks he declared that he heard them
calling in the woods all that afternoon
an odd child she was so silent in her
ways and all
but i was wonderful taken up with her so
domesticated she was
surprising and what about the little boy
said stephen ah that poor boy
sighed mrs bunch he was a foreigner
giovanni he called himself
and he came tweaking his herdy gertie
round and about the drive one winter day
and master had him in that minute and
asked all about where he came from
and how old he was and how he made his
way and where were his relatives
and all as kind as heart could wish but
it went the same way with him
they're an unruly lot those foreign
nations i do suppose
and he was off one fine morning just the
same as the girl
why he went and what he did was our
question for as much as a year after
for he didn't take his hurdy gertie and
there it lays on the shelf
the remainder of the evening was spent
by stephen in miscellaneous
cross-examination of mrs bunch
and in efforts to extract a tune from
the herdy gertie
that night he had a curious dream at the
end of the passage at the top of the
house
in which his bedroom was situated there
was an old disused bathroom
it was kept locked but the upper half of
the door was glazed
and since the muslin curtains which used
to hang there had long been gone
you could look in and see the lead-lined
bath affixed to the wall in the right
hand
with its head towards the window on the
night of which i am speaking
stephen elliot found himself as he
thought looking through the glazed door
the moon was shining through the window
and he was gazing at a figure which lay
in the bath
his description of what he saw reminds
me of what i once beheld myself
in the famous vaults of saint miken's
church in dublin
which possessed the horrid property of
preserving corpses from decay for
centuries
a figure inexpressibly thin and pathetic
of a dusty leaden color enveloped in a
shroud-like garment the thin lips
crooked into a faint and dreadful smile
the hands pressed tightly over the
region of the heart
as he looked upon it a distant almost
inaudible moan
seemed to issue from its lips and the
arms began to stir
the terror of the site forced stephen
backwards and he awoke to the fact that
he was indeed standing on the cold
boarded floor of the passage
in the full light of the moon with a
courage which i do not think can be
common among boys of his age
he went to the door of the bathroom to
ascertain if the figure of his dream was
really there
it was not and he went back to bed
mrs bunch was much impressed next
morning by his story
and went so far as to replace the muslin
curtain over the glazed door of the
bathroom
mr abney moreover to whom he confided
his experiences at breakfast
was greatly interested and made notes of
the matter in what he called his book
the spring equinox was approaching as mr
abney frequently reminded his cousin
adding that this had always been
considered by the ancients to be a
critical time for the young
that stephen would do well to take care
of himself and to shut his bedroom
window at night
and that sensorinos had some valuable
remarks on the subject
two incidents that occurred about this
time made an impression upon steven's
mind
the first was after an unusually uneasy
and oppressed night that he had passed
though he could not recall any
particular dream that he had had
the following evening mrs bunch was
occupying herself and mending his
nightgown
gracious me master steven she broke
forth rather irritably
how do you manage to tear your
nightdress all to flinders this way
look here sir what trouble you do give
to poor servants that have to damn and
mend after you
there was indeed a most destructive and
apparently wanton series of slits or
scorings in the garment
which would undoubtedly require a
skillful needle to make good
they were confined to the left side of
the chest long parallel slits
about six inches in length some of them
not quite piercing the texture of the
linen
steven could only express his entire
ignorance of their origin
he was sure they were not there the
night before
but he said mrs bunch they are just the
same as the scratches on the outside of
my bedroom door
and i'm sure i never had anything to do
with making them
mrs bunch gazed at him open-mouthed then
snatched up a candle
departed hastily from the room and was
heard making her way upstairs
in a few minutes she came down well
she said master stephen it's a funny
thing to me how those marks and
scratches could have come there
too high up for any cat or dog to have
made them much less a rat
for all the world like a chinaman's
fingernails as my uncle in the tea trade
used to tell us of when we were girls
together
i wouldn't say anything to master not if
i was you master steven my dear
and just turn the key of the door when
you go to your bed
i always do mrs bunch as soon as i've
said my prayers
that's a good child always say your
prayers and then no one can hurt you
herewith mrs bunch addressed herself to
mending the injured nightgown
with intervals of meditation until
bedtime
this was on a friday night in march
1812.
on the following evening the usual duet
of stephen and mrs bunch was augmented
by the sudden arrival of mr parks the
butler
who as a rule kept himself rather to
himself in his own pantry
he did not see that stephen was there he
was
moreover flustered and less slow of
speech than was his want
master may get up his own wine if he
likes of an evening was his first remark
either i do it in the daytime or not at
all mrs bunch
i don't know what it may be very likely
it's the rats or the wind got into the
cellars
but i'm not so young as i was and i
can't go through with it as i have done
well mr parks you know it is a
surprising place for rats
is the hall i'm not denying that mrs
bunch
and to be sure many a time i've heard
the tale from the men in the shipyards
about the rat that could speak i never
laid any confidence in that before
but tonight if i'd demeaned myself to
lay my ear to the door of the further
bin
i could pretty much have heard what they
were saying oh there mr parks i have no
patience with your fancies
rats talking in the wine cellar indeed
well mrs bunch i have no wish to argue
with you all i can say is if you choose
to go to the far bin
and lay your ear to the door you may
prove my words this minute
what nonsense you do talk mr parks not
fit for children to listen to
why you'll be frightening master steven
there out of his wits
what master steven said parks awaking to
the consciousness of the boy's presence
master stephen knows well enough when
i'm playing a joke with you mrs bunch
in fact master stephen knew much too
well to suppose that mr parks had in the
first instance
intended a joke he was interested not
altogether pleasantly
in the situation but all his questions
were unsuccessful
in inducing the butler to give any more
detailed account of his experiences in
the wine cellar
we have now arrived at march 24th 1812.
it was a day of curious experiences for
stephen
a windy noisy day which filled the house
and the gardens with a restless
impression
as steven stood by the fence of the
grounds and looked out into the park
he felt as if an endless procession of
unseen people were sweeping past him on
the wind
born on resistlessly and aimlessly
vainly striving to stop themselves
to catch it something that might arrest
their flight and bring them once again
into contact with the living world of
which they had formed apart
after luncheon that day mr abney said
stephen my boy
do you think you could manage to come to
me tonight as late as 11 o'clock in my
study
i shall be busy until that time and i
wish to show you something connected
with your future life
which it is most important that you
should know you are not to mention this
matter to mrs bunch
nor to anyone else in the house and you
had better go to your room at the usual
time
here was a new excitement added to life
stephen eagerly grasped at the
opportunity of sitting up until 11
o'clock
he looked in at the library door on his
way upstairs that evening
and saw a brazier which he had often
noticed in the corner of his room
moved out before the fire an old silver
guilt cup stood on the table
filled with red wine and some written
sheets of paper lay near it
mr abney was sprinkling some incense on
the brazier from a round
silver box as stephen passed but did not
seem to notice his step
the wind had fallen and there was a
still night and a full moon
at about 10 o'clock stephen was standing
at the open window of his bedroom
looking out over the country still as
the night was
the mysterious population of the distant
moonlit woods
was not yet lulled to rest from time to
time strange cries
as of lost and despairing wanderers
sounded from across the lake
they might be the notes of owls or water
birds yet they did not quite resemble
either sound
were they not coming nearer now they
sounded from the nearer side of the
water
and in a few moments they seemed to be
floating about among the shrubberies
then they ceased but just as steven was
thinking of shutting the window
and resuming his reading of robinson
crusoe he caught sight of two figures
standing on the gravel terrace that ran
along the garden side of the hall
the figures of a boy and girl as it
seemed they stood
side by side looking up at the windows
something in the form of the girl
recalled irresistibly his dream of the
figure in the bath
the boy inspired him with more acute
fear
while the girl stood still half smiling
with her hands clasped over her heart
the boy a thin shape with black hair and
ragged clothing
raised his arms in the air with an
appearance of menace
and of an unappeasable hunger and
longing
the moon shone upon his almost
transparent hands
and steven saw that the nails were
fearfully long
and that the light shone through them as
he stood with his arms thus raised
he disclosed a terrifying spectacle
on the left side of his chest there
opened a black and gaping rent
and there fell upon steven's brain
rather than upon his ear
the impression of one of those hungry
and desolate cries that he had heard
resounding over the woods of azerby all
that evening
in another moment this dreadful pair had
moved swiftly and noiselessly over the
dry gravel
and he saw them no more inexpressibly
frightened as he was
he determined to take his candle and go
down to mr abney's study
for the hour appointed for their meeting
was near at hand
the study or library opened out of the
front hall on one side
and stephen urged on by his terrors did
not take long in getting there
to affect an entrance was not so easy
it was not locked he felt sure for the
key was on the outside of the door as
usual
his repeated knocks produced no answer
mr abney was engaged he was speaking
what why did he try to cry out and why
was the cry
choked in his throat had he too seen the
mysterious children
but now everything was quiet and the
door yielded to steven's terrified and
frantic pushing
on the table in mr abney's study certain
papers were found which explained the
situation to stephen elliott
when he was of an age to understand them
the most important sentences were as
follows
it was a belief very strongly and
generally held by the ancients
of whose wisdom in these matters i have
had such experience as induces me to
place confidence in their assertions
that by enacting certain processes which
to us moderns have something of a
barbaric complexion
a very remarkable enlightenment of the
spiritual faculties in man may be
attained
that for example by absorbing the
personalities of a certain number of his
fellow creatures
an individual may gain a complete
ascendancy over those orders of
spiritual beings
which control the elemental forces of
our universe
it is recorded of simon magus that he
was able to fly in the air
to become invisible or to assume any
form he pleased
by the agency of the soul of a boy whom
to use the libelous phrase
employed by the author of the clementine
recognitions
he had murdered i find it set down
moreover
with considerable detail in the writings
of hermes tris magistas
that similar happy results may be
produced by the absorption of the hearts
of not less than three human beings
below the age of 21 years
to the testing of the truth of this
receipt i have devoted the greater part
of the last 20 years
selecting as the corpora villa of my
experiment
such persons as could conveniently be
removed without occasioning a sensible
gap in society
the first step i affected by the removal
of one phoebe stanley
a girl of gypsy extraction on march 24
1792 the second by the removal of a
wandering italian lad
named giovanni paoli on the night of
march 28
1805 the final victim to employ a word
repugnant in the highest degree to my
feelings
must be my cousin stephen elliott his
day must be this march 24th
1812. the best means of affecting the
required absorption is to remove the
heart from the living subject
to reduce it to ashes and to mingle them
with about a pint of some red wine
preferably port the remains of the first
two subject at least
it will be well to conceal a disused
bathroom or wine cellar will be found
convenient for such a purpose
some annoyance may be experienced from
the psychic portion of the subjects
which popular language dignifies with
the name of ghosts
but the man of philosophic temperament
to whom alone the experiment is
appropriate
will be little prone to attach
importance to the feeble efforts of
these things to wreak their vengeance on
him
i contemplate with the liveliest
satisfaction the enlarged and
emancipated existence which the
experiment if successful
will confer on me not only placing me
beyond the reach of human justice
so called but eliminating to a great
extent the prospect of death itself
mr abney was found in his chair his hair
thrown back
his face stamped with an expression of
rage fright
and mortal pain in his left side was a
terrible lacerated wound
exposing the heart there was no blood on
his hands
and a long knife that lay on the table
was perfectly clean
a savage wildcat might have inflicted
the injuries
the window of the study was open and it
was the opinion of the coroner
that mr abney had met his death by the
agency of some wild creature
but stephen elliott's study of the
papers i have quoted
led him to a very different conclusion
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello below there when he heard a voice
thus calling to him he was standing at
the door of his box
with a flag in his hand furled around
its short pole
one would have thought considering the
nature of the ground
that he could not have doubted from what
quarter the voice came
but instead of looking up to where i
stood on the top of the steep cutting
nearly over his head he turned himself
about
and looked down the line there was
something remarkable in his manner of
doing so
though i could not have said for my life
what but i know it was remarkable enough
to attract my notice
even though his figure was foreshortened
and shadowed down in the deep trench
and mine was high above him so steeped
in the glow of an angry sunset
that i had shaded my eyes with my hand
before i saw him at all
hello below from looking down the line
he turned himself about again
and raising his eyes saw my figure high
above him
is there any path by which i can come
down and speak to you
he looked up at me without replying and
i looked down at him without pressing
him
too soon with a repetition of my idol
question
just then there came a vague vibration
in the earth and air
quickly changing into a violent
pulsation and an oncoming rush that
caused me to start back
as though it had force to draw me down
when such vapor as rose to my height
from this rapid train had passed me
and was skimming away over the landscape
i looked down again
and saw him referring the flag he had
shown while the train went by
i repeated my inquiry after a pause
during which he seemed to regard me with
fixed attention he motioned with his
rolled up flag towards a point on my
level
some two or three hundred yards distant
i called down to him
alright and made for that point there
by dint of looking closely about me i
found a rough zigzag descending path
notched out which i followed the cutting
was extremely deep
and unusually precipitate it was made
through a clammy stone
that became oozier and wetter as i went
down
for these reasons i found the way long
enough to give me time to recall a
singular
air of reluctance or compulsion with
which he had pointed out the path
when i came down low enough upon the
zigzag descent to see him again
i saw that he was standing between the
rails on the way by which the train had
lightly passed
in an attitude as if he were waiting for
me to appear
he had his left hand at his chin and
that left elbow rested on his right hand
crossed over his breast his attitude was
one of such
expectation and watchfulness that i
stopped a moment
wandering at it i resumed my downward
way
and stepping out upon the level of the
railroad and drawing nearer to him
i saw that he was a dark sallow man with
a dark beard and rather heavy eyebrows
his post was in as solitary and dismal a
place as ever i saw
on either side a dripping wet wall of
jagged stone
excluding all view but a strip of sky
the perspective
one way only a crooked prolongation of
this great dungeon
the shorter perspective in the other
direction terminating in a gloomy red
light
and the gloomier entrance to a black
tunnel in whose massive architecture
that was a barbarous
depressing and forbidding air so little
sunlight ever found its way to this spot
that it had an earthy deadly smell and
so much cold wind rushed through it that
it struck a chill into me
as if i had left the natural world
before he stirred i was near enough to
him to have touched him
not even then removing his eyes from
mine he stepped back one step
and lifted his hand this was a lonesome
post to occupy
i said and it had riveted my attention
when i looked down from up yonder
a visitor was a rarity i should suppose
not an unwelcome rarity i hoped
in me he merely saw a man who had been
shut up within narrow limits all his
life
and who being at last set free had a
newly awakened interest
in these great works to such purpose i
spoke to him
but i'm far from sure of the terms i
used four
besides that i am not happy in opening
any conversation
there was something in the man that
daunted me
he directed a most curious look towards
the red light near the tunnel's mouth
and looked all about it as if something
were missing from it
and then looked at me that light was
part of his charge was it not
he answered in a low voice don't you
know it is
the monstrous thought came into my mind
as i perused the fixed eyes and the
saturnine face
that this was a spirit not a man i have
speculated since
whether there may have been infection in
his mind
in my turn i stepped back but in making
the action i detected in his eyes some
latent fear of me
this put the monstrous thought to flight
you look at me i said forcing a smile as
if you had a dread of me
i was doubtful he returned whether i had
seen you before
where he pointed to the red light he had
looked at
there i said intently watchful of me he
replied
but without sound yes my good fellow
what should i do there however be that
as it may
i never was there you may swear
i think i may he rejoined yes i'm sure i
may
his manner cleared like my own he
replied to my remarks with readiness
and in well-chosen words had he much to
do there
yes that was to say he had enough
responsibility to bear
but exactness and watchfulness were what
was required of him
and of actual work manual labor he had
next to none
to change that signal to trim those
lights and to turn this iron handle now
and then
was all he had to do under that head
regarding those many long and lonely
hours of which i seemed to make so much
he could only say that the routine of
his life had shaped himself
into that form and he had grown used to
it
he had taught himself a language down
here if only to know it by sight
and to have formed his own crude ideas
of its pronunciation
could be called learning it he had also
worked at fractions and decimals
and tried a little algebra but he was
and had been as a boy
a poor hand at figures was it necessary
for him when on duty
always to remain in that channel of damp
air and could he never rise into the
sunshine from between those high stone
walls
why that depended upon times and
circumstances
under some conditions there would be
less upon the line than under others
and the same held good as to certain
hours of the day and night
in bright weather he did choose
occasions for getting a little above
these lower shadows
but being at all times liable to be
called by his electric bell
and at such times listening for it with
redoubled anxiety
the relief was less than i would suppose
he took me into his box where there was
a fire a desk for an official book in
which he had to make certain entries
a telegraphic instrument with its dial
face and needles
and the little bell of which he had
spoken on my trusting that he would
excuse the remark that he had been well
educated
and i hoped i might say without offense
perhaps educated above that station
he observed that instances of slight
incongruity and such wise
would rarely be found wanting among
large bodies of men
that he had heard it was so in
workhouses in the police force
even in that last desperate resource the
army and that he knew it was so
more or less in any great railway staff
he had been when young if i could
believe it sitting in that hut he
scarcely could
a student of natural philosophy and had
attended lectures
but he had run wild misused his
opportunities
gone down and never risen again he had
no complaint to offer about
that he had made his bed and he lay upon
it
it was far too late to make another all
that i have here condensed he said in a
quiet manner with his grave dark regards
divided between me and the fire
he threw in the word sir from time to
time and especially when he referred to
his youth
as though to request me to understand
that he claimed to be nothing but what i
found him
he was several times interrupted by the
little bell and had to read off messages
and send replies
once he had to stand outside of the door
and display a flag as a train passed
and make some verbal communication to
the driver
in the discharge of his duties i
observed him to be remarkably exact and
vigilant
breaking off his discourse at a syllable
and remaining silent until what he had
to do was done
in a word i should have set this man
down as one of the safest of men to be
employed in that capacity
but for the circumstance that while he
was speaking to me he twice broke
off with a fallen color turned his face
towards the little bell when it did not
ring
open the door of the hut which was kept
shut to exclude the unhealthy damp
and looked out towards the red light
near the mouth of the tunnel
on both of those occasions he came back
to the fire with the inexplicable air
upon him which i had remarked without
being able to define
when we were so far asunder i said when
i rose to leave him
you almost make me think that i've met
with a contented man
i am afraid i must acknowledge that i
said it to lead him on
i believe i used to be so he rejoined in
the low voice in which he had first
spoken
but i'm troubled sir i'm troubled
he would have recalled the words if he
could he had said them however
and i took them up quickly with what
what is your trouble
it is very difficult to impart sir it is
very very difficult to speak of
if ever you make me another visit i will
try to tell you
but i expressly intend to make you
another visit say when shall it be
i go off early in the morning and i
shall be on again at 10 tomorrow night
sir
i will come at 11. he thanked me and
went out the door with me
i'll show my white light sir he said in
his peculiar low voice
till you have found the way up when you
have found it don't call out
and when you are at the top don't call
out his manner seemed to make the place
strike colder to me
but i said no more than very well
and when you come down tomorrow night
don't call out
let me ask you a parting question what
made you cry
hello below there tonight heaven knows
said i i cried something to that effect
not to that effect sir those were the
very words
i know them well admit those were the
very words
i said them no doubt because i saw you
below
for no other reason what other reason
could i possibly have
you had no feeling that they were
conveyed to you in any supernatural way
no he wished me a good night and held up
his light
i walked by the side of the downline of
rails with a very disagreeable sensation
of a train coming behind me
until i found the path it was easier to
mount than to descend
and i got back to my inn without any
adventure
punctual to my appointment i placed my
foot on the first notch of the zigzag
next night
as the distant clocks were striking
eleven he was waiting for me at the
bottom
with his white light on i have not
called out
i said when we came close together may i
speak now
by all means sir good night then and
here's my hand
good night sir and here's mine with that
we walked side by side to his box
entered it closed the door and sat down
by the fire
i have made up my mind sir he began
bending forward as soon as we were
seated
and speaking in a tone but a little
above a whisper that you shall not have
to ask me twice what troubles me
i took you for someone else yesterday
evening that troubles me
that mistake no that's someone else
who is it i don't know
like me i don't know i never saw the
face
the left arm is across the face and the
right arm is waved
violently waved this way i followed his
action with my eyes
and it was the action of an arm
gesticulating with the utmost passion
and vehemence
for god's sake clear the way one moonlit
night
said the man i was sitting here when i
heard a voice cry
hello below there i started up
looked from that door and saw this
someone else
standing by the red light near the
tunnel waving as i just now showed you
the voice seemed hoarse with shouting
and it cried look out
look out and then again hello below
there
look out i caught up my lamp turned it
on red
and ran towards the figure calling
what's wrong what has happened where
it stood just outside the blackness of
the tunnel
i advanced so close upon it that i
wondered that it's keeping the sleeve
across
its eyes i ran right up at it and had my
hand stretched out to pull the sleeve
away
when it was gone into the tunnel said i
no i ran on into the tunnel 500 yards
i stopped and held my lamp above my head
and saw the figures of the measured
distance
and saw the wet stains stealing down the
walls and trickling through the arch
i ran out again faster than i had run in
for i had a mortal appearance of the
place upon me
and i looked all around the red light
with my own red light and i went up the
iron ladder to the gallery atop of it
and i came down again and ran back here
i telegraphed both ways an alarm has
been given
is anything wrong the answer came back
both ways
all well resisting the slow touch of a
frozen finger tracing out my spine
i showed him how that this figure must
be a deception of his sense of sight
and how that figures originating in
disease of the delicate nerves that
minister to the functions of the eye
were known to have often troubled
patients
some of whom had become conscious of the
nature of their affliction
and it even proved it by experiments
upon themselves
as to an imaginary cry said i do but
listen for a moment to the wind in this
unnatural valley
while we speak so low and to the wild
harp it makes of the telegraph wires
that was all very well he returned after
we had sat listening for a while
and he ought to know something of the
wind and the wires he who so often
passed long winter nights there
alone in watching but he would beg to
remark that he had not finished
i asked his pardon and he slowly added
these words
touching my arm within six hours after
the appearance
the memorable accident on this line
happened and within 10 hours the dead
and wounded were brought along through
the tunnel
over the spot where the figure had stood
a disagreeable shutter crept over me
but i did my best against it it was not
to be denied i rejoined that this was a
remarkable coincidence
calculated deeply to impress his mind
but it was unquestionable that
remarkable coincidences
did continually occur and they must be
taken into account in dealing with such
a subject
though to be sure i must admit i added
for i thought i saw that he was going to
bring the objection to bear upon me
men of common sense did not allow much
for coincidences in making the ordinary
calculations of life
he again begged to remark that he had
not finished
i again begged his pardon for being
betrayed into interruptions
this he said again laying his hand upon
my arm
and glancing over his shoulder with
hollow eyes was just a year ago
six or seven months passed and i had
recovered from the surprise and shock
when one morning as the day was breaking
i standing at the door
looked towards the red light and saw the
spectre again
he stopped with a fixed look at me did
it cry out
no it was silent did it wave its arm
no it leaned against the shaft of the
light with both hands before the face
like this once more i followed his
action with my eyes
it was an action of mourning i have seen
such an attitude in stone figures on
tombs
did you go up to it i came in and sat
down
partly to collect my thoughts partly
because it had turned me faint
when i went to the door again daylight
was above me and the ghost was gone
but nothing followed nothing came of
this
he touched me on the arm with his
forefinger twice or thrice
giving a ghastly nod each time that very
day
as a train came out of the tunnel i
noticed at a carriage window on my side
what looked like a confusion of hands
and heads and something waved
i saw it just in time to signal the
driver stop
he shut off and put his brake on but the
train drifted past here 150 yards or
more
i ran after it and as i went along heard
terrible screams and cries
a beautiful young lady had died
instantaneously in one of the
compartments
and was brought in here and laid down on
this floor between us
involuntarily i pushed my chair back as
i looked from the boards at which he
pointed to himself
true sir true precisely as it happened
so i tell it to you
i could think of nothing to say to any
purpose and my mouth was very dry
the wind and the wires took up the story
with a long lamenting whale
he resumed now sir mark this
and judge how my mind is troubled the
spectre came back
a week ago ever since it has been there
now and again by fits and starts
at the light at the danger light what
does it seem to do
he repeated if possible with increased
passion and vehemence
that former gesticulation of for god's
sake clear the way
then he went on i have no peace or rest
for it
it calls to me for many minutes together
in an agonized manner
below there look out look out it stands
waving to me
it rings my little bell i caught it that
did it ring your bell yesterday evening
when i was here and you went to the door
twice why see said i
how your imagination misleads you my
eyes were on the bell
and my ears were open to the bell and if
i am a living man
it did not ring at those times no nor at
any other time
except when it was wrung in the natural
course of physical things by the station
communicating with you
he shook his head i have never made a
mistake as to that yet sir
i have never confused the specter's ring
with the man's
the ghost's ring is a strange vibration
in the bell that it derives from nothing
else
and i have not asserted that the bell
stirs to the eye
i don't wonder that you failed to hear
it but i heard it
and did the specter seem to be there
when you looked out
it was there both times
he repeated firmly both times
will you come to the door with me and
look for it now
he bit his underlip as though he were
somewhat unwilling but a rose
i opened the door and stood on the step
while he stood in the doorway
there was the danger light there was the
dismal mouth of the tunnel
there were the high wet stone walls of
the cutting
there were the stars above them do you
see it
i asked him taking particular note of
his face
his eyes were prominent and strained but
not very much more so perhaps than my
own had been when i had directed them
earnestly towards the same spot
no he answered it is not there
agreed said i we went in again
shut the door and resumed our seats i
was thinking how best to improve this
advantage if it might be called one
when he took up the conversation in such
a matter of course way
so assuming that there could be no
serious question of fact between
us that i felt myself placed in the
weakest of positions
by this time you will fully understand
sir he said
that what troubles me so dreadfully is
the question what does the specter mean
i was not sure i told him that i did
fully understand
what is it warning against he said
ruminating with his eyes on the fire
and only by times turning them on me
what is the danger
where is the danger there is danger
overhanging somewhere on the line
some dreadful calamity will happen it is
not to be doubted this third time after
what has gone before
but surely this is a cruel haunting of
me what can i do
he pulled out his handkerchief and wiped
the drops from his heated forehead
if i telegraph danger on either side of
me or on both
i can give no reason for it he went on
wiping the palms of his hands
i should get into trouble and do no good
they would think i was mad
this is the way it would work message
danger take
care answer what danger where
message don't know but for god's sake
take care
they would displace me what else could
they do
his pain of mind was most pitiable to
see
it was the mental torture of a
conscientious man oppressed beyond
endurance by an
unintelligible responsibility involving
life
when it first stood under the danger
light he went on putting his dark hair
back from his head
and drawing his hands outward across and
across his temples in an extremity of
feverish distress
why not tell me where that accident was
to happen if it must happen
why not tell me how it could be averted
if it could have been averted
when on its second coming it hit its
face why not tell me instead
she is going to die let them keep her at
home if it came on those two occasions
only to show me that its warnings were
true and so to prepare me for the third
why not warn me plainly now and i lord
help me
a mere poor signalman on this solitary
station
why not go to somebody with credit to be
believed and power to act
when i saw him in this state i saw that
for the poor man's sake as well as for
the public safety
what i had to do for the time was to
compose his mind
therefore setting aside all question of
reality or unreality between us
i represented to him that whoever
thoroughly discharged his duty must do
well
and that at least it was his comfort
that he understood his duty
though he did not understand these
confounding appearances
in this effort i succeeded far better
than in the attempt to reason him out of
his conviction
he became calm the occupations
incidental to his post as the night
advanced began to make larger demands on
his attention
and i left him at two in the morning i
had offered to stay through the night
but he would not hear of it that i more
than once looked back at the red light
as i ascended the pathway
that i did not like the red light and
that i should have slept but poorly if
my bed had been under it
i see no reason to conceal nor did i
like the two sequences of the accident
and the dead girl
i see no reason to conceal that either
but what ran most in my thoughts was the
consideration how odd i to act
having become the recipient of this
disclosure i had proved the man to be
intelligent vigilant painstaking and
exact
but how long might he remain so in his
state of mind
though in a subordinate position still
he held a most important trust
and would i for instance like to stake
my own life
on the chances of his continuing to
execute it with precision
unable to overcome a feeling that there
would be something treacherous in my
communicating what he had told me to his
superiors in the company
without first being plain with him and
proposing a middle course to him
i ultimately resolved to offer to
accompany him otherwise keeping his
secret for the present
to the wisest medical practitioner we
could hear of in those parts
and to take his opinion a change in his
time of duty would come round next night
he had apprised me
and he would be off an hour or two after
sunrise and on again soon after sunset
i had appointed to return accordingly
next evening was a lovely evening and i
walked out early to enjoy it
the sun was not yet quite down when i
traversed the field path near the top of
the deep cutting
i would extend my walk for an hour i
said to myself
half an hour on and half an hour back
and it would then be time to go to my
signalman's box
before pursuing my stroll i stepped to
the brink and mechanically looked down
from the point from which i had first
seen him i cannot describe the thrill
that seized upon me
when closed at the mouth of the tunnel i
saw the appearance of a man
with his left sleeve across his eyes
passionately waving his right arm
the nameless horror that oppressed me
passed in a moment
for in a moment i saw that this
appearance of a man was a man indeed
and that there was a little group of
other men standing at a short distance
to whom he seemed to be rehearsing the
gesture he made
the danger light was not yet lighted
against its shaft a little low hut
entirely new to me had been made of some
wooden supports and tarpaulin
it looked no bigger than a bed with an
irresistible sense that something was
wrong
with a flashing self-reproachful fear
that fatal mischief had come of my
leaving the man there
and causing no one to be sent to
overlook or correct what he did
i descended the notched path with all
the speed i could make
what's the matter i asked the men
signalman killed this morning sir
not the man belonging to that box yes
sir
not the man i know you will recognize
him sir if you knew him
said the man who spoke for the others
solemnly uncovering his own head
and raising an end of the tarpaulin for
his face is quite composed
how did this happen how did this happen
i asked
turning from one to another as the hut
closed in again
he was cut down by an engine sir no man
in england knew his work better
but somehow he was not clear of the
outer rail it was just at broad day
he had struck the light and had the lamp
in his hand
as the engine came out of the tunnel his
back was towards her
and she cut him down that man drove her
and was showing how it happened
show the gentleman tom the man who wore
a rough dark dress
stepped back to his former place at the
mouth of the tunnel
coming round the curve in the tunnel sir
he said i saw him at the end
like as if i saw him down a perspective
glass there was no time to check speed
and i knew him to be very careful as he
didn't seem to take heed of the whistle
i shut it off when we were running down
upon him and called to him as loud as i
could call
what did you say i said below there
look out look out for god's sake clear
the way
i started it was a dreadful time sir
i never left off calling to him i put
this arm before my eyes not to see
and i waved this arm to the last but it
was no use
without prolonging the narrative to
dwell on any one of its curious
circumstances more than on any other
i may enclosing it point out the
coincidence that the warning of the
engine
driver included not only the words which
the unfortunate signalman had repeated
to me as haunting him
but also the words which i myself not he
had attached and that only in my own
mind to the gesticulation he had
imitated
you